dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol jonai fahir today
we are going to see that AI video
generation is amazing but it is old news
yes really so this paper just appeared a
few months ago why would this be old
news well what you see here is an AI
that can perform video generation in
goes a piece of text and out comes a
video however this is not video editing
why in this case we don't really have
fine granular control over what happens
in this video however get this this new
paper promises an incredible Leap
Forward where we can actually edit these
videos
how well look it can take a collection
of photos of our favorite teddy bear and
make a video about it and imagine what
it would look like if it were walking
so cool and it gets even better we can
even provide it a video if we are
looking for even more artistic control
and start cutting a papaya and then ask
the AI to transform the papaya into a
cake and it did it just like that wow we
can also make this video a little more
dramatic by pretending there is a flood
going on and of course as a computer
graphics person who loves to write
simulations like this I have to say when
I look at the interaction between the
car and the water I absolutely love what
I am seeing here it does not seem nearly
perfect however I only see flaws when
I'm looking for them specifically with a
critical eye loving it and wait it gets
even better so far we have seen video to
video multiple images to video and now
it promises something even more amazing
what is that it is just one image to
video
what are you trying to tell me that I
provide just this one image here and I
get a full video of someone pouring
coffee that can't be right but hold on
to your papers fellow Scholars just in
case and now let's see
wow it can do this too I can't believe
it and now come the results that made me
fall out of the chair when reading this
paper I wasn't holding on to my papers
enough so I tell you in advance and I
hope you will not make my mistake I
loved how it made an animation of this
black bean plant growing but it turns
out we can give it even more granular
artistic instructions look here we can
not only ask the AI to add a buffalo
bathing in the river but we can make it
gradually zoom out and reveal it an AI
cinematographer how cool is that now of
course not even this technique is
perfect there are some issues with the
horns and more but this is still
incredible progress just one more paper
down the line I am stunned and it gets
even better for instance with this we
can now make really fun artistic choices
get this we can ask the AI to pretend as
if our toy was a real animal and it just
does it how is this even possible oh yes
now I know what you're waiting for let's
pop the hood and look inside
uh-huh yes first our video goes in and
then down scaling happens this means
that the number of pixels and thus the
amount of detail in the image is now
less don't forget this part this will
become important in a moment so one more
time after this point we get less detail
and then something really surprising
happens we make it even worse we add
noise
why is that why would we make this less
detailed video even worse how does that
make sense well this added noise helps
us by enabling us to use previously
existing diffusion based approaches with
that we can use this noisy video as a
starting point and slowly reorganize
this noise to resemble this text prompt
a little more what does this mean
exactly well in this case a completely
new video for us really cool now let's
use our Newfound knowledge of the
algorithm and let's apply it to the sea
turtle this is a real video and now
let's ask the AI to add a shark which it
indeed does excellent you see the
framing of the video Remains the Same
but the shark has been added loving it
however are you seeing what I am seeing
Oh yes we now see the result of this
downscaling step look some detail in the
water waves is now gone this effect is
also particularly visible in the case of
this orangutan also not every result is
perfect of course it truly is a miracle
of AI research that we can transform
this eating monkey into a dancing bear
but then something interesting happens
whoa the bear eater leans forward and
the AI did not think about filling the
background or alternatively the bear
disappears into a black hole in which
case this is perhaps authentic footage
who knows and these are the early days
of AI video editing what a time to be
alive and don't forget this is not just
AI video generation this is so much
better than that this is true video
editing and as always with a work like
this as a true fellow scholar please
always apply the first law of papers the
first law of paper says that research is
a process do not look at where we are
look at where we will be two more papers
down the line so what do you think what
would you use this for let me know in
the comments below this video has been
supported by weights and biases check
out the there isn't offering fully
connected a place where they bring
machine learning practitioners together
to share and discuss their ideas learn
from industry leaders and even
collaborate on projects together you see
I get messages from you fellow Scholars
telling me that you have been inspired
by the series but don't really know
where to start and here it is fully
connected is a great way to learn about
the fundamentals how to reproduce
experiments get your papers accepted to
a conference and more make sure to visit
them through
wnb.me papers or just click the link in
the video description our thanks to
weights and biases for their
long-standing support and for helping us
make better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time